en el centro de moscú este grupo de
activistas se dirige al teatro donde
trabaja una de ellas vamos a hablar con
la dirección del teatro para discutir
seriamente sobre el despido de una
persona por negarse a participar en este
proyecto experimental para inyectar a la
población
en moscú la vacunación es obligatoria
para el 80% de los empleados del sector
terciario
pero galina se negó
a ella encargada del guardarropa de este
teatro y a sus partidarios la seguridad
les negó el acceso
la policía debe venir a la dirección
calle malaya bruna número 4 por el lado
de la entrada del personal
la policía llega
trabajo en el guardarropa y quiero que
me digan por qué no me dejan ir a mi
puesto de trabajo
al final galina para hablar sola con la
dirección pero no logrará su cometido
me recibieron y me explicarán la
situación me dijeron que debía quedarme
en casa me dijeron que entienden que no
quiero un arma pero que tienen que
seguir las directrices de las
autoridades
en lugar de poner en riesgo su trabajo
para evitar la vacunación otros recurren
a una solución ilegal
olga trabaja en un bar compro un
certificado falso para no perder su
trabajo le costó 15.000 rublos algo más
de 200 dólares
le transfería el dinero a un médico me
dieron una cita oficial para la primera
dosis de la vacuna
la vacuna está reservada para uno y la
vacían de verdad no la usan para nadie
más y ya está tengo mi código qr y me
voy al trabajo y el restaurante con
tranquilidad super estará no hay mucha
gente que compra certificados
muchísimos mucha gente compre
certificados
especialmente en el sector de los
servicios
hace poco ha conseguido un nuevo trabajo
en un restaurante hay 10 en el equipo y
todos pagaron campaña
[Música]
numerosos pero incalculables algunos
activistas anti vacunas se organizaron
en un movimiento en este apartamento de
moscú graban un nuevo programa para su
canal de youtube
este es nuestro estudio regularmente
realizamos transmisiones en directo
sobre todos los temas de actualidad hoy
hablamos de los códigos qr y la
vacunación buenos días están viendo de
nuevo al canal solidaridad popular hoy
tenemos a la profesora al pido que está
allá doctora en economía
los invitados entre los que se
encuentran destacados académicos están
preocupados por una serie de mitos que a
su vez discuten en torno a las vacunas
contra el cob y que ya no son vacunas
sino un intento de modificar el adn
humano y nicky atrás y convertirán a la
gente en humanos transgénicos pero para
ser gay que tiene 60 mil 500
suscriptores en youtube el problema es
sobre todo la falta de confianza de los
rusos en el estado la falta de confianza
se debe en gran medida que durante 30
años el gobierno no ha hecho sino
empeorar la vida de la gente yo mismo no
vengo de moscú y puedo ver el estado de
los hospitales en las regiones el estado
debe ganarse la confianza en el momento
en que quiere inyectar al individuo sino
con mucha antelación la gente está
enfadada están enfadados con el sistema
sanitario con la reducción a la mitad
del número de hospitales
camas y nos dice que con todo esto la
gente supuestamente ama a putin una
crisis de confianza que deviene en una
negación de la realidad esa noche una
organización de padres celebraba una
reunión multitudinaria en moscú
y
algunos de ustedes es víctima de las
escuelas pilotos
cuéntenos lo que sucede ahí
en la mira de estos padres están la
enseñanza a distancia las pruebas pcr en
las escuelas y la posible vacunación de
los alumnos en la habitación nadie uso
mascarilla por precaución decidimos no
quedarnos y reunirnos con los líderes en
otro momento para una entrevista
y
nuestro movimiento se formó en respuesta
a la enseñanza a distancia forzada para
los estudiantes y sus padres
porque durante ese terrible año la vista
y la salud de los niños se deterioraron
aunque todo el mundo puede ver que el
hobbit no tiene efectos tan terribles en
las personas como enfermedades como el
cólera o la peste no hay cadáveres en
las calles grupos
pero los hay en las morgues con más de
mil muertes diarias a causa del cob y 19
rusia no deja de batir su propio récord
cuando se le preguntó por el fracaso de
su campaña de vacunación el departamento
de salud de la ciudad de moscú no
respondió a nuestra solicitud de
entrevista